I need to be challenged I need to wake
up each day and break a barrier where
people tell me I can't do it call me a
freak all you want because of my diverse
skill set yeah I'm a double freak but I
enjoy it hi I'm Dan Spitz I am the
master watch maker I also co-founded the
band anthrax
the anthrax it was one of the most
successful heavy metal bands in the
history of music we changed the map so
much that people had to come up with a
term for it called fresh metal but in
1995 I've kind of had enough of touring
I had children and a family and I wanted
nothing more to do but have silence in
my life
as far as watchmaking goes I'm a
third-generation watchmaker I started
taking apart watches in my grandfather's
jewelry store
when I was eight years old after 95 I
wanted to get my pedigree and be able to
take apart what's considered
complications or just crazy avant-garde
watch making which is the equivalent of
thrash metal in watchmaking the only way
to do that is in Switzerland I was lucky
enough to gain access to a school where
six people are chosen from around the
world every three years as far as the
timepieces that I work on the watches
you usually start a 50,000 and go up to
two a three million it is not with a
battery not with a circuit board you can
get into two three four thousand pieces
inside a timepiece that all have to do
certain things so if there's a problem
you might have to rip apart the entire
engine we call it a movement figure out
what the problem is rebuild the watch
there's no road map to the pieces when
you're in that zone in that watch and
trying to find that problem when you
finally execute whatever that is it's a
feeling of euphoria and it's just like
when you're in the recording studio and
just like you when you're on stage and
we have zero room for error and I take
that into my watch making